I accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is drew Scanlon and
some of you may know me as the blinking
white guy meme I was working as a video
producer at a website that covered the
video game industry called Giant Bomb
part of my duties as a video producer I
not only was shooting and editing a lot
of video but because we were a really
small team everyone was always on camera
kind of all the time and we did this
weekly show called unprofessional
Fridays for our premium subscribers and
it was basically just us sitting around
playing a bunch of video games the dry
bomb fans are amazing and they're very
very passionate so there were animated
gifs being made of us constantly so that
part was not really new to me when that
happened it always was sort of contained
within the giant bomb community or like
maybe video games at large the video the
meme was recorded in just one of these
sessions where we get together and play
games and my coworker Jeff was playing a
game called Starbound which involves
farming and he said so I've been doing
some farming with my with my hoe here
and kind of Atilla
what kind of a so what is it we heard
about and that's the reaction I made to
that sort of double entendre I guess and
it was just like one joke in a two-hour
show it didn't at the time it didn't
stand out as anything particularly
special I think one of the weirdest
things is that four years went by
Between the villains when that video was
shot and when the meme kind of reached
its critical mass I don't really know
why that happened I always just
attribute it to Internet chaos theory
the point where I noticed that it had
sort of blossomed into this larger thing
like outside of the gaming community was
people mentioning to me on Twitter that
they saw it used somewhere else like
their mom used it on Facebook or
something like she has no idea who you
are but she used it on Facebook and
there were also a lot of tweets using it
that had like tens of thousands of
and retweets once I got a sense of how
large it was you it was honestly a
little scary because it felt very much
out of my control I mean nothing on the
internet is within anyone's control
really but it just there's something
about the scale that was a little
alarming I was very thankful that that
that clip was fairly innocuous something
I said may have been twisted into
something bad or it could have been more
embarrassing like that has certainly
happened to people on the Internet at
some points it almost doesn't feel like
me like I just made a face on a live
stream it was it was other people that
you know trimmed that out and then
discovered a way to use it there's still
not a lot of association with with me
people think it's Cary Elwes they think
it's Michael C Hall and so you really
have to dig a little bit to figure out
to trace it back to again a real person
I have been recognized one time as the
meme guy because of the fact that it was
so long between the filming of the video
and when it kind of got popular I looked
pretty different like I had more facial
hair my hair was longer so shout out to
the guy at the Dublin Best Buy memes are
this weird different thing they're
different from you know celebrities like
actors or something people expect actors
to be real people they don't necessarily
expect that and this is just my theory
they don't necessarily expect that from
memes because memes come from the
internet I don't know that people
necessarily will notice someone and say
hey I think I know that guy from a meme
it actually happened right at the time
where I was leaving Giant Bomb to start
cloth map cloth map is a video project
on YouTube but it's supported by my
audience on patreon some people I think
jokingly associated like ah Drew's a big
meme now so he's gonna go out on his own
when like there was no correlation there
at all my audience sends me around the
world to explore different countries
through the lens of the
and sports that they play games are a
lot like food they're this thing that
people come together and do with their
family and friends and it's a
commonality across all cultures on a
trip for cloth math I went to Brazil and
I met some people who had heard somehow
that the guy from the blinking white guy
meme was coming like not that was not I
wasn't there to be a meme I was there to
like you know ask them questions about
video game development in Brazil and
they were all very excited to to meet me
which you know that was strange but but
kind of fun which I think strange but
kind of fun kind of sums up the whole
thing I think the reality is a weird
thing I think if you chase it it doesn't
come I think people are really good at
detecting deception and when people are
being inauthentic that is easy for
humans to detect I think if if if this
happens to you I think my advice would
be just to embrace it you can't you
can't hide on the internet so whatever
is out there is out there and just try
as best you can to have fun
[Music]
Oh